hello and welcome to the new old review
your source for everything anime and
manga and today it's Jojo o'clock again
because I've just finished Golden Lent
and I have brain thoughts the worst kind
of thoughts because this particular Jojo
look it was an interesting experience
and first up there will be spoilers for
part 5 of Georgia's bizarre adventure if
anybody watching this actually cares I
mean you're watching your review so it
should probably be evident but just in
case be aware of that and one other
disclaimer I also apologize in advance
for butchering Italian names with my
horrific Australian twang to begin
though I have to say that golden wind is
100% the best produced series from the
perspective of pristine art and
animation I really wasn't quite sure
about it going into this because the art
is initially super abrasive for me
coming off the most simplified cutesy
tone of part 4 but this notion was very
quickly dismissed and I really
appreciated the artistic Drive thrown
into golden wind which I think was a
necessary decision because it was taking
place in the real world and not just
anywhere in the real world but Italy and
Italy is such a wonderfully detailed and
content rich feast for the eyes all on
its own so it's only natural that the
characters and animation matched that
style
speaking of Italy though that setting
was a pretty incredible highlight for me
because I've traveled all around that
country and I felt myself recognising a
disgusting amount of places that our
characters found themselves in I mean
nah Polly Rome Venice Pompeii almost
every new location gave me this sense of
incredible nostalgia and that's
interesting because that's not something
that I got from battle tenancy which
also had a large stretch of time in
Italy but it never really focused too
much on its geography so golden wind is
a huge win for me there now in terms of
genre golden win starts out by
portraying a seedy crime drama which I
was really excited for especially after
hearing about the scale of the
organization all of its cells and the
mysterious boss but in the end I'm not
exactly sure if it's stuck to that genre
the thing about golden wind is it
actually reminds me a lot of Stardust
Crusaders almost the entirety of the
series is based on travel except in
golden wind it is done significantly
better because the goal of travel
continues to change however the
resulting format is much the same
essentially every time our merry band of
gangsters arrive somewhere or attempts
to get somewhere there is always a stand
user or two waiting for them and there
were times and golden winds where that
got simply tiring which is exactly the
same feeling that I had but part three I
mean for example when they all boarded
the plane and were flying to Sardinia
the writing was on the wall
quite literally actually because I've
seen what happens when
Jojo characters bought a plane and it
always ends with them crashing so in
this particular case the stand that
appeared which was super cool I love the
idea of a stand and during after death
but it felt like nothing more than an
obstacle artificially thrown in the way
preventing the story from continuing and
I also take the point the specific
scenario was also designed to awaken
Trish but that's just how it felt
another few episodes dealing with yet
another roadblock and the guess in
general it was kind of disappointing
that things did just proceed like that
because I was hoping for a more radical
genre shift with maybe some antagonistic
characters who would be relevant beyond
the stand of the weak storyline just as
a lot of them became relevant in part 4
but speaking of characters now johner
quite probably my least favorite Jojo
aside from Jonathan I will say that he
had been incredibly intrigued for the
first couple of episodes because I do
really love the explanation of why he
exists being the spawn of deer but with
Jonathan's body that is a fascinating
exploration waiting to happen right
there hot Joe star part ultimate evil
dick back and I was very much hoping
that that would play into Jonah's arc
over the course of the series I kinda
know maybe every now and then Jonah
would just snap lose any sense of
morality and get lost in that deal
aspect of himself that he would have to
keep in check with the Joestar part of
him and thus continue the seemingly
eternal struggle but obviously none of
that happened and I can't honestly say
that Jonah really developed much at all
during series the point at which he
begins golden wind is very much the
point at which he ends from an internal
character perspective he starts out
wildly driven super smart and with an
innate sense of justice and then nothing
ever happens to change or evolve that
once again this is another case where
the majority of the dramatic weight
falls to those around the Jojo and I
have to say the golden went in that
regard is quite possibly the best in the
series thus far all of bucchi Artie's
team including butcher Artie himself
have their own wonderful character arcs
and the one that comes to mind right
away is a Bucky oh who spends a lot of
his time in the series learning to trust
Jonah and we get to see his early days
as a police officer and it makes his
death so so impactful come to think of
it we get to see flashbacks of every
character on the team including Joe no
to be fair and yet guess yeah it is easy
to understand why he does thinks he does
but Jonah just like he doesn't feel
human to me
he's a deus ex machina who looks like a
human designed to assist this band of
flawed but incredibly charming
characters on their human quest and I
guess that's my ultimate problem
he has no flaws every move he makes is
cold and calculated to perfection like I
can't think of a scenario off the top of
my head where Jonah actually made a
mistake and encode consequences as a
result whereas if I cast my mind back to
josuke Oh Joseph they're covered in
faults at every step of their respective
journeys that lead them to increasingly
more interesting and highest-stakes
situations which makes it much easier
for me to identify with them however
like I said it doesn't really matter
because golden went offers a collective
of fantastic characters to latch on to
and I found myself really looking at
this series as butch karate story or in
some cases even Mies does because he
gets featured a lot like very
disproportionately to the rest of the
group you can tell that our key
absolutely loves him but that's fine
because I also love him as well as his
stand so in my opinion that was just our
key playing to the strengths of hook
cold and went to became to the other end
of the spectrum now our ultimate
antagonist to the boss or Diavolo and he
was pretty fascinating to follow until I
found out who he was oddly enough I very
much preferred the shadowy figure to the
person he ended up being presented to us
as because he ended up being another
evil for the sake of evil character
however he did come equipped with two
fantastic features one of which is his
split personality with dopey Oh anytime
doppio was on screen I was 100%
compelled because that is the kind of
stuff I love I mean to think that
someone like Diavolo would have such an
incredible flaw in the very
comparatively easy to kill and super
quirky doppio personality it's really
great and I also enjoyed how well
implemented doppio was to take maximum
advantage of the situation that the two
had found themselves in it was actually
one of those things where for much of
the series I was convinced that doppio
would be the key to defeating Diavolo
because he was built up as such an
invincible combatant thanks to King
Crimson but Dobby I was certainly not
invincible and I don't know maybe he
might have gotten into a situation where
he had a change of heart due to some
sort of profound character growth and
committed suicide thus killing Diavolo
as well but instead the split
personality served a more technical
purpose which we'll get into right now
though the second thing that Diavolo has
going for him is King Crimson this stand
is automatic and nothing short of a
terrifying pleasure to watch although I
think I'd probably be confused as hell
if there wasn't a very very similar
ability in hunter hunter which obviously
pays homage to this which would be Sir
I'd next parallel future King Crimson is
really cool ability though and I really
enjoyed how anytime you saw that -
I'm skip happened it was a big oh [ __ ]
moment because you knew that it had been
activated and whenever this thing is
activated it is very very not good
it's a stupidly powerful stand there
well they're not the most ridiculous
surprisingly because gold experience
Requiem is a thing and that seems to be
legitimately invincible and capable of
forcing people into endless death loops
which was super cool but my god
unbalanced a cell I mean these
characters are getting closer and closer
to becoming literal gods in every
incarnation of this series what I do
wish we got to see a lot more of their
the characters from four major series
like when Koichi appeared initially I
was thrilled because I assumed that he
would play a big part in golden wind
kind of like Joe Torre's role in part 4
but then he was nowhere to be seen in
the opening so that made it pretty clear
to me that he was only there very very
temporarily I did find myself missing
that connection to the greater Joe Joe
versa and that would come back somewhat
in the form of polnareff it was a
definite highlight for me especially
after he turned into a turtle
but overall golden wind felt more
disconnected from the roots of Joe Joe
then even the slice-of-life story that
was diamond is unbreakable and I'm not
saying that's a bad thing either
because as an individual story golden
wind works very well and muddling it up
with too much Joe Joe history and
outside spreads probably would have hurt
it quite a bit but as someone who was
constantly interested in the greatest
saga of the Joe Joe lineage I was
slightly disappointed to have all of
that kind of dismissed eeeh
speaking of dismissed though I really do
not buy at all that there was no way for
polnareff to contact Arturo in order to
deal with this whole boss situation
especially if T of all we believe that
polnareff was dead I mean just put on a
disguise and fly to wherever in the
world the man who can stop time is and
then BAM problem solved sort of I mean I
get that the organization is powerful
and all but this part of the story is
flimsy as hell I mean just like most
excuses to keep Joe Terra out of the
fray however in the context of golden
wind alone polnareff was great and I
loved that he ended up being some sort
of Turtle key spirit now let's talk
about the ending though big sigh of very
mixed feelings about this The Lost
handful of golden wind episodes were
very very weird to me firstly because at
the climax of the entire series the
entire crew did a body swap which you
know is a tried and tested storyline
which usually gets played for great
amounts of comedy but I found this to be
such an odd spot to place it like we're
really gearing up for the final conflict
of the series and then this massive
mechanic is thrown at us out of nowhere
it was quite jarring and super strange
for the finale of the
series two mostly play out with
characters inhabiting other bodies but I
will say that it did lead to a nice
dramatic standoff when Jonah realized
Diavolo was sneakily hiding inside one
of them I guess the body swap narrative
is just something you'd expect to see
maybe halfway through the series once
you've established your characters
enough to realize why this is weird and
interesting but while the dramatic
stakes aren't at their highest and the
final thing I'll say on this is that the
body swap really undercut neurons his
death for me because we didn't even get
to see him pass away in his own body and
I personally was still reeling from the
bizarre situation that it happens yeah
the emotion of losing another team
member got very lost in translation for
me and the other thing I wasn't so much
of a fan or for the last two episodes in
general another super strange narrative
choice here where after defeating
Diavolo
we immediately cut into a two episode
monster-of-the-week story featuring
rolling stones and I get that lots of
people will probably disagree with me on
this but this story should have played
out near the beginning of the series
because it really does not have enough
dramatic weight to carry the ending of
it I mean the one profound thing it does
do is provide a tragic explanation of
how fate was changed to kill three
people instead of just boo karate which
was genuinely touching and sad but this
entire story did not need to be here
specifically you could have shown the
whole rolling stones thing at the
beginning of the series and then added
an extra flashback right at the end here
we're like mr. sees the rock in Rome
putting an addendum of how fate changed
to decide the three characters were
going to die and I guess for me it just
broke the flow of the series and then
when we did cut back to Jono and
everyone else for the final moments
everything felt like an incredibly
rushed ending because I guess he's the
boss now and we're done cool next part
and I'm assuming that this is how it
happened in the manga as well because I
really can't see an animation company
taking this sort of Liberty and
storytelling if anything the whole
rolling stones business feels like an
OVA and while there is something nice
about seeing the gang back together once
again after losing so many members I
don't feel like it adds anywhere near
enough to justify being the final piece
of story told in golden wind but overall
while I've probably focused much more on
the negative thoughts and the positive
ones I once again had a pretty great
Jojo experience with part 5 it's a bit
sad that this is the last part available
in anime form but it's been a fun
journey which I will now have to take to
the manga format and speaking of next up
we have stone ocean something that I
know Jack all about except this time
around we have a female Jojo which
be fun and if I had to guess the genre
from this one I guess I'd say Prison
Break story but that's probably reading
too much into things just because of the
bar and the handcuffs because you know
if we go by the same things that we see
first up in part three then I probably
would have said prison story as well
rather than epic global adventure so we
shall see wish me luck
but that pretty much does it for this
review jared is Bizarre Adventure part 5
golden wind if you enjoyed this video
and the content this channel produced in
general then please do consider donating
to the new ultra few patreon because the
support of all of your amazing people is
what continues to make this channel
possible and if patreon isn't quite your
style then please do leave this video a
like share or subscribe because it also
helps for this channel an incredible
amount and if you'd like to join the fun
at any time and please do head over to
my discord server where a wide array of
shenanigan retakes place on a daily
basis and finally please do comment with
your thoughts uncle the wind this has
been the new world review and I'll see
you next time
[Music]